It's great to welcome back to the program
today.
Richard Wolff, who is of course professor
Ameritus
economics at my undergraduate Alma Mater,
the University of Massachusetts, currently
a visiting professor at the new school university
in New York City.
The latest book called Understanding Marxism
is available all of the normal places including
in digital form a professor wolf.
Great to have you on.
Again.
Glad to be here.
It really, yeah.
So let's start digging into some of the ideas
that we are seeing put forward by the 2020
democratic challengers.
On the one hand, we've sort of seen the mainstreaming
of some ideas that even as recently as four
years ago were considered relatively niche
and left including um, oh, uh, a wealth tax
including medicare for all in a sort of more
serious and particular way.
What's your overall sense of this shift?
And do you think that there is any policy
in particular that goes far enough in terms
of the type of systemic change that may be
needed?
Or are we really still talking about sort
of bandaids and fixing things around the edges?
Well, I basically think that to get to the
core of your question that we are still seeing
the vast preponderance of proposals from the
Democratic contenders.
Those are bandaids.
That's right.
Those are the attempt, uh, to see.
Honestly, I'm certainly better than the Republicans
can manage what the failures and flaws and
problems of our economic and political system
are.
Uh, but I do think it's still early in the
process of facing up to all of it so that
they are emotionally, uh, bandaids.
They are mostly attempts to take what we already
have some of and make it more comprehensive,
make it more generous and hope against hope
really, that these adjustments will somehow
be adequate.
What I do find remarkable and I see it in
the shifting over to Medicare for all and
taxing the wealth.
There is the beginning of an understanding
that these bandaids have to go than one used
to think bandaids had to go that it wasn't
just a little tweaking of the tax rates and
so forth, but something as fundamental as
a imposing a tax on wealth itself in the form
of stocks and bonds, which this country has
avoided doing a for most of its history.
So it is a recognition that we need more and
yet our hope that relatively modest things
will be sufficient to what to change what's
going on.
I think that's the real cool, really interesting
thing that capitalism and America is now produced
such an extreme level of inequality, such
an extreme experience of capitalism's instability.
The crash of 2008 that 10 years we've just
lost trying quote unquote to recover from
it.
The fact that the entire financial community
knows that either this year or next year we're
going to have a recession and who knows how
that this one will be.
All of this royaling of the realities we live
in is pushing our politics on the right over
toward Mr. Trump and all that he represents.
But on the left in the directions that your
question that raises,
I saw a critique of a that you, you were involved
in in some way, shape or form.
I forget exactly on what show related to the
idea of universal basic income, sort of in
the mode that Andrew Yang has been proposing
it.
And I've talked about this a lot, including
with him and I have some problems with the
particulars, but to sort of paraphrase, and
I hope I'm doing it correctly, one of your
more general criticisms was that giving people
$1,000 a month is not going to solve a lot
of the structural issues that exist regarding
inequality, regarding the relationship between
most workers and their employers, et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I thought that that was a good critique,
but I wondered couldn't the same opposition
besides good against food stamps, against
WIC, et Cetera, et cetera.
And it doesn't strike me as a reason not to
do it as long as we sort of recognize its
limitations so to speak.
So I guess to clarify, are you against something
like universal basic income period?
Like are you against doing it or is it merely
that you want to make sure that we understand
that it's not structurally changing the problems
of the system?
It's mostly the latter.
I don't oppose doing these things any more
than I oppose giving welfare to, to people
who are denied the job.
But because the, the liberal part of American
politics has long ago given up the critique
of the structure, the notion of basic change,
the whole debate of the 20th century about
capitalism versus socialism, which by the
way is coming back now.
But because the liberals gave up on it, people
like me have to hammer at the inadequacy of
these bandaids less the idea the that we either
have no bandaid or we have a bandaid.
But that's something beyond the bandaid is
somehow unthinkable or undiscussable.
So I want to point out that for example, if
you give everybody a guaranteed basic income,
but some people go to work and have a job
and earn way more than all of that, you're
just inviting what our old history shows us,
which is sooner or later the people who work
for and end a living will be, how shall I
put it?
Politely helped to see the people who get
the guaranteed income as in some sense living
off the taxes they pay and therefore the tension
between the employed and the unemployed that
has always dogged capitalism will simply resurface
in an adjusted form around the question of
a basic income.
Therefore, I would much rather face the reality,
which is if we have technological change that
makes it possible for fewer people to be more
productive than they used to be.
So that instead of needing a hundred workers
to make something, we only need 50 we had,
we can cut the labor costs in half.
Capitalism's solves that problem in a particular
way.
It fires have the people, right, because then
you can produce the same amount with half
the people sell it.
Let's presume for simplicity at the same price
and what you get as revenue.
You now don't have to pay half the workers
you use.
Do you keep that money as your profit?
Which is why the technological change attracts
you in the first place.
But that's the capitalist answer, but it ought
to be hours.
Why?
Because the alternative way of handling a
doubling in productivity, which is what we've
just discussed, would be to give everybody
half the amount of hours per day to work.
That way everybody keeps their job.
Everybody keeps their income.
What the benefit of technology is, what we
really always promised people, namely leisure
and in the society, not driven by profit,
that the technology would be advanced because
the game is to the majority in more leisure
rather than the game to a minority in the
way of more profit.
These are the questions that are structural
and basic and these are the ones that still
remain a bit too scary for virtually all of
the candidates in the Democratic Party.
To to get ahold of.
I actually did a commentary yesterday about
the latest jobs numbers and I said it's fine
to talk about 75,000
versus the expected number.
It's fine to talk about 0.2% wage growth versus
0.5, but fundamentally none of this stuff
is actually addressing these incoming and
growing issues of the relationship of humans
to work.
And my analysis of the hundred employees versus
50 due to the technological change has been,
and I wonder if you agree with it that the
pure free market capitalist, so, uh, sort
of, um, uh, reception of that technological
change that allows you to double productivity
would be you fire half the workers.
And that's also bad for other elements of
the economy because now you have 50 workers
that no longer have money with which to buy
things from other businesses.
The pure socialist solution might be, well,
we've socialized ownership of the company
to begin with, so the workers share in all
the gains.
Now, here's where I wonder if we disagreed
the social democracy.
Uh, a solution might be the business owners
are entitled to some piece of that productivity
gain, whereas some significant portion would
be divided up by the workers.
Is that fair?
Is that pie in the sky?
No, I think that's a perfectly reasonable,
I mean it assume something namely that the
owners are in some sense different from the
people who are working there really change
the system.
That difference would disappear, but let's
keep it for a while.
Let's assume that there are owners are capitalists
on the one hand and workers on the other.
It would be an enormous step forward.
I would agree to have a discussion in which
the question is raised.
Okay, we now have a technical advance we can
install that year in the business we have
and that gives us what?
It gives us a choice.
We can either use all of it for profit and
fire half the workers or we can use none of
it for profit and give all the workers basically
I have time employment situation at the same
wage or, and this is simple arithmetic.
We can split the difference.
We can have a conversation, a discussion,
maybe a vote as to what portion of the games
from a technological advance are given to
workers in the form of leisure versus employers
in the form of profits.
That already would be a level of the democratization
of the workplace, which is what I stress anyway
would be a major step forward.
And by the way, while this is a revolutionary
idea here in the United States, social democracies
in Europe, this is not a new idea.
This is in fact what goes on in Germany and
France and Italy, unions often or bargaining
with employers on precisely how to divide
technical and other kinds of advances in terms
of sharing in a sense in the benefit.
It's not revolutionary, it's not challenging
the private ownership of the industries and
the empathy and the enterprises.
But it is saying that what happens with an
advance of technology is something that has
to be discussed and worked out like everything
else about the workplace and not something
simply to be determined to the advantage of
one side and the exclusion of participation
on the other.
Well, that gets me to something else I want
to hear your thoughts on which is that there's
a very specific and productive, I think, debate
to be had about capitalism versus socialism,
social democracy versus unregulated capitalism,
et Cetera, but are you concerned about what
I have seen as sort of some confusion between
social democracy and socialism?
I've done a number of segments where I'm saying
if we even really want to seriously have this
debate, we have to make sure that we're calling
things what they are and socialism, where
the means of production is socialized is different
than something like the Swedish system or
the Danish system, which is a capitalist system
that says we are going to use more of the
government revenue to ensure that the standard
of living doesn't go below a certain level.
Is that an academic distinction or is that
a serious distinction that we need to understand
to really talk about this stuff?
I could not be more 100% the latter and not
the format.
In other words, this is not academic or abstract
or nitpicking or anything like that.
This is of the essence.
And that's part of our, our backwardness here
in the United States for a half a century
at the, after the end of World War, socialism,
communism, Marxism, all of that was prescribed.
It was declared trailers.
It was declared evil.
It was whatever you want.
And people were good Americans who kept away
from it, didn't think about it, didn't read
about it, didn't debate about it, nothing.
And now that capitalism has shown itself to
need basic change to an awful lot of people
for whom it is a working real well, there's
a process of rediscovery and, and that's all
to the good.
But in that process, you're right, the confusion
and the misuse of language and the naming
of things that really ought to be named that
way because a hundred years of literature
and a debate, uh, had clarified these differences.
But Americans are just learning.
Let me give you an example.
Two weeks ago, I was invited and I did it
to be on the town hall of the Fox television
system for an hour answering questions from
a live audience, uh, debating, by the way,
Lou Dobbs and Neil Cavuto and all those people
sitting next to me, uh, Herman Jane or the
candidate for president so that we had a debate
was capitalism versus socialism and they're
on display was this arresting fudge of words
and ideas in which the same word socialism
was applied to Sweden, to Italy, to China,
to Russia, to Venezuela.
I need the chaos and confusion that is being
sown now, partly on the other side, they want
the lump all of these things together, right?
I understand that.
But if you're interested in these things as
real options for our society in difficulty,
which I am and many Americans are, that has
to be clarified and I think is very good.
Even if it's difficult that you begin to say,
look, this is social democracy or this is
democratic socialism.
This is something else too, which we can give
a variety of names that have been used, but
we have to begin clarifying this so we can
have the conversation and the political action,
uh, focus on what it is we actually want.
Well that's good.
It makes me feel better that I haven't been
wasting my time with, uh, with those segments.
We've been speaking with economist Richard
Wolf.
The new book is called understanding Marxism.
It's available everywhere you went in.
Imagine books are available.
Uh, Professor Wolf, always great to talk to
you.
They could talk to you David and hope we can
do it again soon.